est conscient que ça va prendre écrit
provoquer des réactions c'est quelque
chose que la ligue nationale nous nous a
offert c'est quelque chose que les 32
propriétaires ont voté pour et ça fait
partie de la prochaine étape dans les
vosges l'évolution de la ligue nationale
le canadien de montréal a dévoilé lundi
son nouveau chandail qui sera orné d'un
logo de la banque royale rbc décision
qui a provoqué quand même beaucoup de
réactions cette semaine jeff mason qui
rappelle qu'il y à déjà des logos sur
les casques et que c'est une évolution
selon lui qu'on voit dans toutes les
grandes ligues en amérique du nord
aujourd'hui les jets de winnipeg ont
annoncé que leur chandail sera orné du
logo de la canada-vie les oilers
d'edmonton ont annoncé qu'il n'avait pas
l'intention d'ajouter un tel le go pour
l'instant avec nous ce soir ray lalonde
analystes ancien chef marketing des
ventes des canadiens de montréal bonsoir
et la longue ça coûte combien comme sun
commandite sur un chandail mais
généralement c'est ça peut partir d'un
lot d'un assemblage de propriété qui
inclut la publicité du tableau
électronique peut-être un logo sur une
bande sur la glace et on fait si on veut
une offre globale et parmi ceux là se
trouve le bijou de la publicité pour les
canadiens de montréal c'est à dire la
présence sur le chandail à domicile donc
c'est probablement auto pour rbc le de
2,2 à 3,4 millions parce que c'est aussi
pour une demi-saison seulement les
matches à domicile d'akabo hisser seul
et 40 matchs à domicile et de la
publicité dans la patinoire il ya de la
publicité sur les borgnes de la
publicité sur les casques illicites et
durant tout le match il ya de publicité
pendant le match entre les publicités
ont fait est ce qu une limite à la
publicité dans le sport j'irai que c'est
un peu
inquiétant pour le consommateur de voir
autant publie ce type sa vie et
infiltrés est envahi par des messages
publicitaires mais en contrepartie 6
c'est la locomotive du sport majeur dans
le monde entier sans publicité topoline
détenteurs de droits qui paient autant
d'argent que je parle de milliards de
dollars annuellement à chaque propriété
pour diffuser et donc clairement pas de
publicité pour détenteurs de droits
diffuseur mais moins d'argent dans
l'industrie - de salaire v et des
franchises qui valent beaucoup moins
cher forcément donc la publicité c'est
le point central où tout tourne autour
dans le sport juste que les billets plus
que les billets et est ce que la ligue
nationale où le canadien où les jets ont
besoin d'argent supplémentaire au point
de m legault sur le chandail c'est une
bonne observation actuellement gérés oui
parce que la pandémie a fait très mal
aux équipes sportives et
particulièrement au canada où on n'avait
pas la même autonomie qu aux états unis
pour attirer des fermes et ça fait mal
ça c'est des millions de dollars par
match
quand on joue des matches 1 100
spectateurs mais le match se joue mais
ne dépend que sont les mêmes mais ya pas
de rentrées d'argent alors c'est
important c'était le moment de le faire
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on
l'envisagent puis depuis 2007 la nbi qui
est un produit comparable en termes de
matches en termes d'habitat autre lancer
un test mais cinq ans plus tard c'est un
succès sans équivoque donc il faut
suivre la tendance et pour penser qu'on
doit toujours être aux traditionalistes
ou puristes éviter des nouvelles
propriétés l'objectif étant de créer de
nouvelles sources de revenus mais est-ce
que ça dénature paul shanghai oui mais
pour mme aux dépens de millions de
dollars d'offres et d'opportunités qui
se présente parce que même si les
chandails origin au sexe sont sacrés
mais le chandail des yankees de new york
l'est tout autant où les red sox de
boston où les cowboys de dallas et dès
l'an prochain général le baseball majeur
vaut faire ce geste là qu'on va voir la
publicité envahir les 30 équipes du
baseball majeur dont les blue jays c'est
juste une question de temps c'est dans
la mls et dans l'envié
cette année dans la ligue nationale l'an
prochain au baseball et la nfl n'attend
que la poussière retombe pour décider ce
qu'elle va charger pour avoir un logo
sur le champ des dépanneurs ou des
steelers des cas bolt mais est ce qu'on
s'en va nous sommes que des sports si je
me trompe pas le soccer ya beaucoup plus
de publicité le quasiment le logo de
l'équipe est une publicité le logo de
l'équipe prend la place si on veut du
ces pour le capitaine ou du logo de rbc
ouais ici le publicitaire l'annonceur
qui domine le champ des mets en europe
pour les grandes équipes sportives de
foot manchester united les repos bayern
munich psg real madrid ça peut valoir
75 à 100 millions de dollars par année
par équipes la présence par exemple
pendant des années de chevrolet un
produit américain sur le chandail de
manchester united mais ça rayonne
mondialement donc je voudrais ne
pourrait jamais avoir cette espèce de
visibilité à l'échelle mondiale sans
être sur le chandail de match tu faisais
le canadien de montréal est rendu avec
cinq institutions financières pourquoi
les bancs est morte en commandite et de
canadiens dont les banques ont de
l'argent c'est clair deuxièmement les
banques sont en compétition sont en
concurrence ils veulent
notre attention ils veulent aller
chercher des clients des nouveaux
clients à voir leur argent puis les
canadiens ont innové dans un sens en
créant une espèce d'opportunités où on
avait des jardins à l'époque oui puis
par la suite s'est rajouté doucement à
la banque nationale comme investisseur
du club et ensuite la banque scotia
comme
porte parole de cette équipe au canada
de la ligue nationale avec leur fille
mineure peut jouer au hockey et des
programmes pour les jeunes et l'an
dernie cibc sur le casque et
soudainement il ne manquerait presque
rbc ouais alors rb6 attendu pour aller
chercher comme j'ai dit l'objet le plus
prisé c'est à dire le chandail rouge et
canal hier le fondateur d'amazon jeff
bezos c'est le patron d'ing et phil
rogers godard était assis ensemble pour
un match de la nfl brise-vue ensemble ça
veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire que on se
félicitent mutuellement de l'arrivée de
la nfl le plus grand produits sportifs
en richesse sur la planète avec pras une
vidéo une aux pièces de contenus
importants pour augmenter les
abonnements en prime une relation
exclusive un match par semaine gerald
qui va leur donner un point 2 milliards
de dollars us pour un match par semaine
pour une saison une entente de plusieurs
années mais on a vu récemment a raconté
signé avec la mls mais pour acheter la
totalité des matchs alors impôts goog o
amazon sont tous dans la business de
contenu netflix ils veulent tous en
avoir de nous ils se doivent de
rafraîchir le menu le sport en direct
c'est une des dernières franchises et
dernière pardon frontière pour aller
chercher vous êtes toujours passionnant
et la londe merci beaucoup merci en
creuse pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit